I find information in the membership
career to using hydrogen peroxide for oxygenation.
But it did not open.
Can we start with one drop and go up food grade?
No, I am not a big fan of using hydrogen peroxide
for cancer.
And let me pull up our site here because I'm pretty sure I have a blog
almost done that.
Let me make sure it's live real quick.
Yeah, I use your peroxide for cancer.
So if you just search the blog, hydrogen peroxide for cancer,
it's called hydrogen peroxide for cancer.
Not so fast.
And there's a YouTube video that is not linked.
So that's what you're talking about.
So let me look.
We actually had several YouTube videos taken down by YouTube
because they were home.
I guess some.
I don't know.
I'll be racist or something.
But yeah, they just went yesterday.
They said we pulled your YouTube video.
There's something.
Okay, so I will fix that link for you real quick.
And then you can look at it.
So I'll just go back to that blog post in a couple of minutes.
And then you will be able to see it.
Here I fix it.